hi I'm Vanessa Marano and I'm Laura
Marano we're here at BuzzFeed and we're
gonna be talking about our first first
incorrect rumor you write about yourself
I mean I feel like mine is probably like
dating a co-star cuz that's literally
never happened the first time I saw how
much money I apparently oh that's so
crazy
is so wrong so wrong I wish it was true
but that is for everybody yeah I've
worked with a lot of actors and every
single time like someone inevitably
googles somebody and it's like wow I
didn't realize like would you invest
your money in and every single one's
like what are you talking about that is
not even remotely close to accurate
Laura what is your first memory that
comes to mind on the first step onset of
Boston an alley on when we were testing
I didn't meet Calum then but I met Ross
and why I know brainy for years I'm just
walking in and everyone's talking sure
there's a lot of people and Ross is just
there by himself on his guitar and if
that's not a description of Ross Lynch I
don't know what is Vanessa first memory
that comes to mind of the first day on
set a sociopath
one of the first scenes but I don't know
if this was the first day might be the
second day was a shooting in front of
the Kennish house and us meeting Daphne
and Regina and like the families that
were switched all meeting each other and
my character being very mean very and
Katy taught us all different words in
sign language that day also there was
like a bathroom broke down in the middle
of the house so that was a whole moment
the other thing I remember like
specifically of like a first on switched
was we had to do a lot of wardrobe
fittings for the pilot and Katie and I
had kind of met at the test but we
didn't really she was cast already and
they just basically had her in the room
to check how tall all the other girls
were in classic uh but the first time we
like actually interacted with each other
was we had like a really last-minute
fitting right before shooting because
they couldn't decide on outfits and so
we happen we were basically sharing a
fitting and just like changing and
getting naked in front of each other and
like going back and forth back forth and
then they order us food but they wanted
us to stay in the outfit
sirs were gonna come down and approve it
so they wrapped us in plastic wrap and I
have a picture of me and Katy eating
Chinese food on the floor of the fitting
room literally wrapped I'm flattered
that's pretty awesome there you go first
kiss mine was on camera
adorable why it was fur I did an
independent film called easy and I was
10 years old and the characters like
have to have their first kiss but say
what you did in the scene oh I'm getting
there
so the characters had their first kiss
and it's supposed to be cute and sweet
and like it's a flashback to the older
girl hiding her first kiss and it
supposed to take place in the 80s and so
the way that she decides to kiss the boy
as they were watching Madonna's like a
virgin video and so my character leaves
while he's watching the video goes and
gets a blonde wig and dresses up like
Madonna and start singing like a virgin
to seduce him into a first kiss also the
boy did not want to kiss me
I can say that now because I know him
now and we're very friendly but he was
not into it he was like this seems like
a weird thing this is gross kissing's
weird and then the scene didn't make it
oh yeah they cut the scene that's right
I forgot about that
I'm not in that movie you're not in
Hayley
my first kiss was under dance and so it
was normal so was everything as normal
as those kisses can be and I just
remember I could tell I was such a jerk
I could tell he was really nervous and I
like took a lot of comfort in that I was
like I was like not gonna do it on the
dance floor
I'm like that I'm not doing so basic so
basic so we went like upstairs to the
venue and we kissed and I was like you
got to give me more than that
oh and then we kissed again and we
missed each other's mouths and then we
kissed again and he's good so third
time's the charm for a first kiss first
embarrassing moment on set oh I know
this one was working on a show called
the comeback and I was 13 years old so
obviously embarrassed all the time
and my character was like a fashionista
so I was always amazed like really crazy
outfits and this one outfit was like a
flowy skirt that we used as a dress so
it was like tied up like a strapless
dress but it was a skirt and I had to
walk in front of the camera and like be
on my phone like oh I'm so bored and
then walk past the camera that's what
the shot was as I did that it felt like
legitimately and like I was wearing bras
at this time so it wasn't like insane
but it was also just lying down I like
that was very very uncomfortable that
scene got cut too weird
okay I'm embarrassed when I think about
it now I don't think I was embarrassed
in the moment so JC Penney commercial
yeah I was crazy like crazy I was I mean
it was five so I guess it's expected but
it was like I kept calling the director
of my dad my dad was there on set with
me and the guy who was playing my
brother in this JC Penney commercial I
was like he was older than me and I was
like beating him up like I was just like
slapping him I was kicking him I was
just like really just vivacious I would
say do you cringe thinking about when we
were in Finding Nemo together and you
started telling everybody about your
imaginary friend Christina who died by
snakebite didn't let anyone know that
she was imaginary um yeah I would I had
an imaginary friend named Christina and
she died with her family they were
hiking in the mountains and they were
eaten by a king cobra and you know what
happens every once in a while right I'm
just a canoe first celebrity you ever
met I was like Muhammad people who were
like celebrities but we were so young it
you like Anthony LaPaglia we were like
like me Anthony so we worked with him
without race which is the first project
we ever did together um and it was the
first project we ever did theatrically
yeah I had no idea who he was but I knew
that my parents were really excited
about him so then that made me really
excited so I like a really starstruck
not knowing really who he was being six
and being like oh my god oh my god like
it's Anthony oh my oh my god and I bite
oh I don't think we pronounce his name
no what's Italian it's like Labine mia
anyway so I was like super star struck
but I just remember being like who's you
weren't probably Gilmore Girls because I
was such a big fan of that show like
that was probably the first time I was
like freaking out about pretty oh wow
this is Lorelai this is Luke this is
Rory this is real this is Taylor dough
Z's market first time you're recognized
in public
probably from Gilmore Girls that would
make the most sense on the first time
that comes to my memory is um from doing
fifth graders more than a fifth grader
oh yeah and I remembered I would get
recognized a lot and I was like whoohoo
that's cool a few years later I got
recognized from being the girl in Modern
Family
to which our slide I'm not her but thank
you for enjoying my work I also have
been recognized for doing a great job on
Pretty Little Liars
yeah don't know great work who on Pretty
Little Liars but we all know yeah first
thing you do so current okay when you
have time off
oh I sleep yeah I've always lived too I
feel easier and watch The Real
Housewives
I don't do that I sleep so now watch
either an animated movie a rom-com or a
Christopher Nolan film which I think are
basically on the same genre guys Real
Housewives absolutely as Real Housewives
is that but first piece of advice you'd
give someone who's trying to become an
actor or singer what if I gave the
advice to the singer
take an acting class do a play be doing
the thing that you're doing even if
you're not necessarily making money at
it yeah I just be acting be writing be
whatever it is that you want to do
creatively and eventually you will make
money off of that you just want to be
humming that craft than working and
being around and people who are friends
who you value them creatively in what
they do - first big red carpet event oh
I think it was the Teen Choice Awards
yeah it was probably the Teen Choice it
was definite engine and it was not a
year that either one of us was nominated
nothing
first celebrity friends you made Laura
Marano
Vanessa yes I would say for you me okay
yeah I guess Megan Megan would be the
first that's so crazy to feel like Mike
my friend Megan Martin who was wrong we
never worked with Eggman's I think never
I did I I mean I meet Megan because we
work together so that's why this is a
weird moment I met Megan because I knew
her boyfriend at the time and she worked
with me um I would wear at least say
Raini Rodriguez because I usually didn't
work with kids but the one time I did
was for a show called huff
um and she was one of the like three
kids so we're working and I just
remember like thinking she was the
coolest right off the bat she was so
funny she was so sweet
her mom was so sweet I think Rico was
there too and obvious it was like way
before modern family and I don't even
know if he was like acting yet and then
I worked with her years later in Austin
alley and it was awesome she was like
cool first job first job like Center
it's a it was a JCPenney commercial that
I'm not proud of my first Union job was
a Toyota Sienna commercial and it only
aired on Telemundo
Hughes expansion let her know I had a
speak Spanish for a Mercedes Benz
commercial and I had to have a dog come
up and lick my ear and to do that they
put peanut butter behind your ear and
it's not an awesome experience
especially when you're wearing the
blonde wig like a virgin and see
[Music]